guillaume naud secrétaire général
adjoint du syndicat option lui bonjour
monsieur no mercy est d'être avec nous
en direct alors castaner aujourd'hui à
dharmanand ministère de l'intérieur est
ce que ce casting change quelque chose
pour vous pour nous c'est pas le
changement de ministre de l'intérieur
qui va changer grand chose dans notre
mission au quotidien
on jugera comme tous les autres
ministres intérieur par leurs actes et
par leur décision parce qu'il va voir ce
qui ce qui va être décidé la ligne
directrice qui va être donnée alors
sonné en réunion avec les fans dégâts
les syndicats qui est en cours qu'est ce
que vous attendez concrètement de cette
réunion un grand chose aujourd'hui on
n'attend plus grand chose des locaux
discours qu'on a pu avoir ces dernières
années on attendait sachs co et puis
d'arrêter un petit peu cette saison fut
images qu'on a de la part des
organisations syndicales traditionnelles
et de la part de nos ministres
successifs pour vous attendez des
actions plus de mots concrètement gérald
darmanin devra prioriser selon vous que
de pratiquer faire incessamment sous peu
écoutez il ya un mal profond qui règne
au sein de la police nationale
désormais si vous voulez les le soin qui
a porté en tout cas auprès des policiers
c'est une écoute on a une demande un
manque de reconnaissance depuis de
nombreuses années au détriment de nos
missions
aujourd'hui on attend réellement d'être
écouté et si on n'est pas écoutés on se
fait entendre
alors monsieur nô on l'a vu vous l'avez
dit exactement ça se passe très mal en
ce moment avec la police est une des
manifestations depuis quelques semaines
est ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
qu'est la nomination de gérald darmanin
parce qu'on l'a vu en ces premiers mots
ça a été la police je vais la soutenir
c'était ses premiers mots est-ce que
vous pensez que ça peut changer quelque
chose
comme à chaque changement de ministre de
l'intérieur au premier ministre on a
toujours espoir d'y avoir
changement une vraie fée décision
politique qui interfère en tout cas qui
qui permet à la police nationale d'aller
mieux
malheureusement depuis 20 ans on a
beaucoup contestée de m d'amélioration
nos missions sont de plus en plus
compliquée la délinquance augmente de
plus en plus en particulier la nuit sur
lequel on a une activité de 5 % qui
augmente tous les ans et une absence
totale de reconnaissance un oubli total
des policiers de terrain et c'est là où
aujourd'hui on va rappeler que les
policiers de terrain sont là existe et
qu'il faut un peu plus
voilà de reconnaissance pas simplement
des beaux discours il faut des actes il
faut des prêts un vrai signe fort pour
les policiers sans quoi le dernier
rempart qui s'offre aujourd'hui au
gouvernement
hé bé s'effondre un petit à petit alors
j'en ai envie de dire c'est pas vraiment
de chance 1 le ministre de l'intérieur à
peine nommé est critiqué parce que l' on
le rappelle est visé par une plainte
pour viol quel regard portez-vous sur
cela en nous je rappelais en option nuit
on est un syndicat créé par des nuits
tout de la police nationale en vingt
jours on a réuni 70 % des policiers de
la nuit c'est à dire bien plus que ce
que les syndicats traditionnels ont fait
en vingt ans le regard on n'est pas là
pour juger directement sa vie privée les
condamnations
quand je voulais dit on et sur les actes
les actes qui vont nous toucher
directement et qu'ils ont tiré et touché
directement les actions qu'on peut mener
sur le terrain
alors vous êtes au niveau du syndicat
pour les policiers qui travaillent de
nuit
qu'est ce que vous demandez quelle est
la différence avec les policiers qui
travaillent de jour et des talents de
vous demander quoi de plus on n'est pas
là pour demander des choses
supplémentaires on n'est pas x 6m
syndicats je crois que ce qui a été
monté en plein jour sur option nuit
c'est c'est plus qu'un syndicat national
c'est un mouvement un vrai mouvement de
contestation c'est un peu l'armé 10
nuits 2 qui se réunit aujourd'hui parce
qu'on se reconnaît plus dans nos
organisations syndicales qui en on pense
qu'ils nous ont totalement oublié pris
par toute l'activité qu'ils ont à gérer
au niveau de leur syndicat national et
mais aujourd'hui ce qu'on a besoin
clairement
c'est de ne plus être payés 97 centimes
de l'heure de nuit je sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte mais la police
nationale sur le terrain celle qui est
confrontée aux appels au secours
celle qui confrontait aux coups de feu
celle qui confrontait aux coups de
couteau et à l'augmentation de cette
délinquance
aujourd'hui on travaille pour quelque
chose qui est dérisoire on fait de la
braderie avec les nuiteux et on a je le
répète 1 97 centimes de l'ordonner ça va
choquer peut-être beaucoup de personnes
mais c'est ce qu'on est payés chaque
nuit et non pas pour la totalité des 12
heures puisqu'on travaille à 12h08 c'est
à dire la moitié de la journée d'une
journée 24 heures eh ben on est sûr
quelques heures en raison de 8 euros par
nuit pour pour les risques sont en cours
sur le terrain monsieur nô
merci d'avoir été en direct avec mon je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général adjoint du syndicat option nuit
merci